justement il y avait la danse des belles
mères à l'époque on faisait encore ça et
oui alors il est nos mères dangers avec
les jeunes gens avec qui nous nous
sortirons c'est à dire que les jeunes
n'avaient pas cette haine que maintenant
ils ont ouvert certaines personnes âgées
dans le bord de lait où je me promène
ces jours-ci tout le monde m'a parlé
d'une restauratrice sympathique fine
cuisinière et dans la vie dit-on n'a pas
cessé d'être agité j'ai eu envie de la
rencontrer et effectivement Henriette
Moreau est un personnage attachant
attachant et serviable à toute heure de
la journée elle est prête à faire une
petite omelette jambon et une salade je
vous disais qu'elle avait eu une vie
agité c'est vrai elle a commencé à 21
ans par rentrer dans les ordres mais les
séances hebdomadaires de confession
collective lui invite des plus elle a
fini par refuser d'y participer alors
oui j'avais déjà l'esprit contrariant je
n'avais pas l'esprit d'obéissance ni
l'esprit d'humilité si vous préférez
parce que dans ce milieu il faut être
raisonnable soumis et moi j'avais quand
même pas cet esprit là de soumission et
l'humilité je l'ai peut-être acquis avec
l'âge ça serait maintenant j'accepterai
beaucoup de choses mais à 20 ans vous
n'acceptez pas beaucoup de choses
j'imagine qu'à l'époque la flagellation
s'était terminée déjà non non ça
existait encore comment ça se passait ça
se passait d'abord dans l'obscurité
puisque les reviens c'est ce sont
obligés de se flageller les jambes
c'était une religieuse qui vous ferait
pas parce que c'est un obscurité et ça
faisait mal
c'est vous qui vous tapez alors vous le
savez ça vous fait mal hein alors si
vous voulez vous faire mal vous faites
mal mais si vous avez pas envie de vous
faire mal vous ne faites pas mal
je me souviens une fois j'ai j'avais
coincé la mienne avec une de mes
collègues qui était à côté et les deux
disciplines c'était accrochées
un petit peu on avait reconnu ma voix et
facilement j'ai été remerciée par la
suite vous devinez
cette discipline
comme une petite chaînette et puis il y
avait cinq branches qui représentait les
marques du Christ qui a été vérifier
alors les mains les pieds et puis le
coeur alors il y avait c'est un petites
branches et avec lesquelles vous fassiez
comme du petit fil de fer
à peu près
alors si vous étiez courageux de vouloir
souffrir mais
voilà si vous trouviez utile peut-être
je sais pas moi j'ai jamais tellement
apprécié ce genre d'exercice et
maintenant dans les couvents c'est très
différent oui très très différent c'est
beaucoup plus libre c'est beaucoup plus
large c'est beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup
plus aéré il y a beaucoup beaucoup moins
d'hypocrisie qu'il n'y avait à l'époque
et les soeurs sont beaucoup plus
détendus beaucoup plus les femmes comme
les autres
qui l'ont fait ou qu'ils le font enfin
ce n'est pas quand même recommandé alors
à ce moment-là le manque de pauvreté
parce que j'achète des produits beauté
ça coûte très cher le mec j'ai à Paris
s'acheter des des fonds de teint qui
sont excessivement chers ou des crèmes
ou des choses comme ça non mais j'en
connais beaucoup qui ne le font pas
peut-être qu'il y en a quelques-unes qui
le font et d'autres non
et après être sorti du couvent Madame
Moreau oui je suis allée me relaxer je
suis parti de s'habituer à la vie
sociale normal très dur pour moi ça a
été très dur même que je sois resté que
6 ans de Me réadapter à la vie normale
parce que j'étais habituée à des
horaires j'étais habitué à faire telle
et telle chose et je m'étais habituée et
après que je me suis sentie libre
j'étais comme perdue vous voyez j'avais
plus personne qui était là pour me dire
pour me dire où j'avais pu une règle à
respecter j'avais plus rien alors
j'étais complètement perdue je me
souviens à table chez moi j'étais
toujours assise la dernière mon père
ça soit à la supérience à soi et ça ça
soit après et de retour dans la vie
sociale normale vous avez petit à petit
rencontrer des garçons
quand les garçons mais je suis partie je
ne suis pas resté dans le Médoc je suis
parti en Haute-Savoie j'imagine
vous avez profité un peu pour aller
danser pour aller au bal non j'aime pas
le bal
j'aime pas danser j'aime beaucoup
regarder dans ces autres j'aime
l'ambiance d'un bal j'aime bien regarder
danser les autres et moi je n'aime pas
danser d'abord je n'ai pas l'oreille
musicienne et ensuite je ne sais pas
chanter
parce que j'avais des collègues qu'il y
avait des amis d'y aller et c'était très
très sympathique de se retrouver avec
les cavaliers les futurs
nos mères dansaient avec les jeunes gens
avec qui nous nous sortirons
je trouve que ça c'était très
sympathique c'est à dire que les jeunes
n'avaient pas cette haine que maintenant
ils ont ouvert certaines personnes âgées
vous voyez oui chez certains c'est de la
haine
parce que peut-être qu'on leur a pas
d'autres choses vous voyez il y a je
suis certain jeunes une certaine haine
des personnes âgées ça c'est vrai il
faut le reconnaître d'autres ils le font
par je sais pas parce qu'ils ont pas
reçu une éducation satisfaisante ou je
ne sais pas moi mais il y a quand même
si chez les jeunes on sent qu'il n'aime
pas des fois que des vieux soient là ou
alors si aussi discutez avec vous vous
voyez que vous rentrez le bain avec eux
que vous riez avec eux que vous en avez
que là ça va vous les avez avec vous
mais si vous avez l'air de leur faire
une seule observation et toi la mimi
tais-toi alors bon ce genre de choses
moi je me suis entendu dire mais chéri
vous que celui qui me l'a dit je
m'approche je lui dis moi à la mémé je
suis venu vers toi je vais t'expliquer
je sais qu'une mémé parce que je n'aime
pas qu'on m'appelle toi là mais oui
écoute non non
non mais je lui dis pourquoi je
m'appelle la mémé qu'est-ce que je te
dois que tu m'appelles la mémé
Sacha tu me respectes parce que moi je
t'ai respecté j'étais correct avec toi
pourquoi tu m'appelles la mémé
vous répondre oui ça c'est sûr mais
quand ils sont tout seul il s'échappent
même des fois une tribu il s'échappe
aussi tout à l'heure vous avez dit que
vous n'aviez pas d'enfance
pas eu d'enfant ça a été mon grand
désespoir d'ailleurs
de ne pas avoir eu d'enfant ça veut dire
quoi vous avez pas raté votre vie à
cause de ça quand même oh non c'est pas
rater ma vie parce que je me suis quand
même occupé je vous dis je me suis
occupé de ma jeune sœur
puis elle en a eu alors je me suis
occupé de sa fille je m'en occupe encore
non je suis pas une question de rater sa
vie non parce que vous savez la vie
c'est pas une chose qu'on peut dire
c'est raté c'est pas vrai vous pouvez
pas dire qu'une vie ratée c'est
impossible parce que si vous comblez ce
vide par autre chose alors votre vie
n'est pas ratée par quoi vous l'avez pas
les autres
comment ça politiquement
oui ça m'est arrivé oui oui oui
mais déjà beaucoup de mes aventures mais
ça fait rien ça on va en parler de toute
façon je l'ai fait je vais vous dire ça
justement parce que je n'avais pas
d'enfant j'aurais des enfants je
n'aurais pas risqué si mes aventures
enfin ça fait rien je vais vérifier elle
est belle
alors là si vous avez faim vous avez
bien remué la salade oui ça va
tout à l'heure la cuisine vous me
parliez de d'un certain engagement
politique c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre
engagement politique si bien dire
c'est un peu fort je dirais que j'aime
bien m'occuper de choses politiques
parce que c'est important on en dépend
de la politique on a envie on en meurt
bon j'imagine que on doit porter un
témoignage si on est chrétien on porte
un témoignage si on est communiste
n’importe notre
moment le grand coup et ce qui est le
plus crucial à ce moment c'est ça c'est
cette marche qu'il y a côte à côte entre
les chrétiens et les communistes vous
êtes communiste je ne suis pas
communiste
mais je ne suis pas contre les
communistes
ce qui me ce qui me détache d'eux à un
certain niveau c'est l'athéisme moi je
suis chrétienne et je suis croyante donc
j'ai la foi vous avez militaire
méditer non j'ai assisté à pas mal de
réunions avec eux dire que j'ai médité
ça serait beaucoup dire parce que si
j'avais militaire avec eux je serai avec
j'y serai là encore présente avec mais
je veux pas dire que je vais m'engager
parce qu'on veut pas faire deux choses à
la fois être chrétien et être communiste
et vous avez vous êtes entré au parti
communiste ou quoi
vous avez pris votre carte à l'époque
j'ai eu pris une carte du parti
communiste pour fréquenter des
communistes pour étudier ou en été le
Parti communiste par rapport à ce que je
l'avais étudié en garantie 47 48 avec la
bella Rosa qui s'occupait de nous dans
le mouvement d'action catholique donc je
faisais partie c'était un peu du
voyeurisme
si vous voulez vous appelez ça comme ça
enfin moi j'aime bien savoir avant de
critiquer quelqu'un de dire ils sont
comme ça mais il faut aller voir comment
ils sont et alors c'est le tout de dire
foufoule et les saké faut les saboter
faut d'abord aller voir si vraiment il
mérite une d'être contré ou d'avoir une
correction il faut le voir vivre parce
que dans beaucoup de communistes vous
avez beaucoup d'employés vous avez quand
même beaucoup c'est la masse des
ouvriers qui sont bon des fois c'est les
gens qui sont ignorants de certaines
choses qui sont partis là parce qu'ils
avaient rien d'autre à côté pour se
défendre son service de parti communiste
puis qui dans le fond sont peut-être pas
plus communiste que que n'importe qui et
comment vous les avez trouvé alors ces
communistes moi ce que j'ai fréquenté
ceux qui font partie des des chefs moi
je les ai trouvés bien
oui parce que ce sont des gars décidés
ce sont des gars qui sont courageux qui
n'ont pas peur de leur opinion qui ne
cachent pas leur opinion comme souvent
je reproche à certains chrétiens de
cacher leur opinion vous voyez et le
Médoc comment il va s'en sortir là dans
l'avenir parce que je trouve un peu un
peu triste ou nez pas très vivant oui
mais je pense qu'ils s'en sortira à la
longue de façon à ce que quand vous
voyez bien aussi nous comprendre puis
nous aider qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait pour
qu'ils s'en sortent dans le Médoc il
manque beaucoup de choses il manque je
vous l'ai déjà dit un pont vous voyez un
pont sur la Gironde pourquoi il manque
un pont bon il manque un peu parce que
vous voulez aller quelque part vous
voulez aller en ordonnez vous voulez
aller dans les Charentes tout de suite
via Bordeaux Bordeaux ou alors il faut
prendre le bac soit à la marque alors où
vous l'avez ou vous le ratez ou vous
allez la Pointe de Grave il fait beau ou
il fait pas beau le bas qui part l'hiver
où il ne pars pas tandis qu'avec un pont
même un pont en péage ils arriveraient à
récupérer leur pont ça serait
merveilleux un peu
[Musique]